AIRPLANES HAVE BEEN TRAVELING
THE SPEED OF SOUND FOR YEARS.
TAKE OFF THE WINGS,
ADD SOME WHEELS,
AND YOU'VE GOT A GREAT PLATFORM.
Combs:
IMAGINE SITTING IN THE COCKPIT
OF AN F-104 STARFIGHTER JET,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THE COCKPIT
OF MY LAND SPEED CAR IS.
Bodden:
THIS IS BASICALLY A MISSILE.
YOU ARE DRIVING A MISSILE
AT SPEEDS APPROACHING
THE SPEED OF SOUND.
IT'S ACTUALLY REALLY NICE
AND COMFORTABLE. [ LAUGHS ]
BACK AROUND
THE TURN OF THE LAST CENTURY,
IT WAS BELIEVED THAT
YOU COULDN'T GO
MORE THAN 20 OR 30 MILES
AN HOUR, AND IT WOULD KILL YOU.
I DON'T THINK THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE.
SO IF YOU'RE IN THIS
LAND SPEED RACER,
AND YOU'RE MOVING ALONG,
IT'S GOING FAST ENOUGH TO WHERE
IT COULD ACTUALLY TAKE OFF.
YOU DON'T WANT TO FLY
IN A VEHICLE THAT CAN'T FLY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE WIND
PUSHING IT DOWN ONTO THE TIRES
BY THE WAY THE FRAME IS MADE.
A LAND SPEED CAR HAS CANARDS.
NOW, THESE ARE THE LITTLE
MINI WINGS YOU SEE UP FRONT.
AN AIRPLANE,
THE WING IS CURVED ON TOP,
WHICH CREATES LOW PRESSURE
AND PROVIDES LIFT.
ON A CAR, IT WOULD BE
THE OPPOSITE.
YOU WANT TO CREATE DOWNFORCE
RATHER THAN LIFT.
THE TRICK IS NOT TO CREATE
TOO MUCH DOWNFORCE
BECAUSE THEN
THE CAR'S DOWNFORCE,
IT COULD ACTUALLY DIG THE CAR
INTO THE GROUND,
WHICH WOULD BE HORRIBLE.
NOT ENOUGH DOWNFORCE
COULD CAUSE THE CAR TO FLIP,
CARTWHEEL, OR JUST COMPLETELY
GO OUT OF CONTROL.
AS IN SO MUCH ELSE
ON THE LAND SPEED RACER,
IT'S ABOUT PUSHING PHYSICS
TO ITS ABSOLUTE LIMITS.
THIS WHEEL ARRANGEMENT HAS
TWO MAIN WHEELS IN THE BACK,
TWO STABILIZING WHEELS OFF
TO THE SIDE IN THE MIDDLE --
YOU CAN THINK OF IT ALMOST AS
TRAINING WHEELS ON A BICYCLE --
AND THEN YOU HAVE
YOUR FRONT WHEEL,
WHICH PROVIDES YOUR STEERING.
IT'S NOT LIKE THESE CARS
HAVE SUSPENSION.
THEY'RE NOT MEANT TO HANDLE
THE END OF THE LAKE BED
OR THE EDGES OF THE LAKE BED,
THE BUMPY PART.
BECAUSE WEIGHT IS A BIG CONCERN,
THE ONLY SUSPENSION
IS ON THAT FRONT WHEEL.
Narrator:
AND LOW WEIGHT IS IMPORTANT
DUE TO NEWTON'S
SECOND LAW OF MOTION --
ACCELERATION IS EQUAL TO FORCE
DIVIDED BY MASS.
SO WHEN YOU INCREASE THE MASS,
AS WITH A HEAVY CAR,
YOU DECREASE THE ACCELERATION.
BUT WHEN YOU DECREASE THE MASS,
AS WITH A LIGHTER CAR,
YOU INCREASE THE ACCELERATION,
GETTING CLOSER TO SETTING
A NEW LAND SPEED RECORD.